One could say a lot about the connection between classification and cognition.
This is because classification is ubiquitous in cognition. You're driving a car
on the street, you see a friend driving his car, you look, take a look at
the car, and you see a Porsche. Classification. You're on a computer program,
the output is faulty. You look at the output, decide on the bug.
You name the bug. Classification. You go to a doctor with certain signs and
symptoms, the doctor names a disease category, classification. The reason
classification is so ubiquitous is because it allows us to select actions.
Once the doctor knows what the disease category is, he can suggest a therapy.
Once you know what the bug is you can decide on a repair for
that bug. If action selection indeed is a very productive characterization
of intelligence then we can see why classification is central to cognition.